so uh i i think i i probably know
almost half the room my name is eric
zemer um i was one of the early clutter
employees i was i was at clutter from
about 21 employees to about 800
employees and recently recently uh left
the mothership and started a new company
called scouting data i'm going to go in
great depth um
with what scaling data does i'm going to
talk much more about
how we use kafka and
unlike
gwen i think who gave you a bunch of
really good options i'm going to be
really opinionated and highly specific
and tell you all the things that you
should not do with kafka and hopefully
let you guys uh hopefully you can learn
something from that
so i'm definitely not going to talk
about how kafka works i'm going to talk
about sort of how we use it and how we
stitch things together
and the goal is to kind of fill the
spaces in between so i think a lot of
kafka talks
go into some hand wavy stuff around
there are producers and they send data
to kafka you know hand wave hand wave
and then stuff happens and then there
are consumers that pull data out of
kafka hand wave hand wave and like data
winds up in your in your systems and
everything's fantastic
um unfortunately though that's that
winds up not being true and i think gwen
actually got into a bunch of the the
hard parts right you get into data
duplication and all these other kinds of
things so you know these are the this is
like the hand-wavy part of producers and
to kafka kafka into consumers consumers
into storage and or processing systems
um what could possibly go wrong so this
is a list of stuff that can go wrong
um so to start with you know getting
data in and and gwen just gave a bunch
of really good examples but you have
these you know are they apis are there
legacy data sources like files on on
disk or tailing files or
files and directories that need to be
parsed and and i agree with gwen that
everything has structure um
saying things are unstructured means
that it's just a bunch of bytes and
nobody knows what to do with a bunch of
bytes um the message schema thing i'm
going to get into things like keys and
duplicate data duplication partitioning
offset management
where does transformation go or where
should transformation go for doing like
inline transformation
um what do you do with dead letters so
traditional like you know for those of
us who are you know used like
traditional enterprise like esb type
stuff there's always that case that
somebody sends you bunk data and when
you get a bunk message that can't be
parsed
um what do you do with it how do you
handle that
um so there's a concept called dead
letter queues or where you sort of take
data that's malformed you shove it into
a place for later inspection by a human
or alerting
durability to target systems again gwen
just talked a whole bunch about this
things like data center replication so
at linkedin that you know in within the
kafka community there's a project called
mirror maker that will mirror uh
topics um and brokers the the problem is
is that people in my experience also
want to do things like filter and
throttle and rate limit and do all this
other kind of stuff so you might have
eight data centers and you want to
aggregate all data of a particular type
and you might have you know uh
heterogeneous uh event types or message
types on the queue and so on and so
forth so there's there's all this sort
of
space in between the you know that
triplet of you know producer takafka
kafka to consumer and consumer to
storage and processing um these things
aren't kafka's responsibilities so
people say like well why doesn't kafka
do that and it's because kafka does what
it does very very well and this stuff is
stuff that needs to be dealt with
outside of the system you wouldn't want
a system that sort of tries to handle
all this for you
um
and the problem is is that all of these
these different things just you know
depend on lots and lots of different
stuff so
latency requirements batching uh the
types of storage systems whether you
have things like atomic commits and like
all this other kind of stuff and how you
you know the shape of your data and how
you want to deal with things whether or
not duplication is a problem or
something you worry about
you need to think about them even if
kafka doesn't so i think that you know
that the team at linkedin you know jay
included you know these are people that
studied like distributed systems and
data management and transaction logs the
reality is the majority of the world is
not like that um and that's something
that i learned in my my time at cloudera
so for most people you want it to just
work for your use case and like there's
a bunch of details that you might not
want to spend your time on but you know
at the end of the day nothing is free
there's no magical technology where like
data like magically shows up and and
only shows up once and transactions
aren't the thing and so on and so forth
so scaling data has two main pieces to
its product one is a data infrastructure
that's built on top of all the open
source components like hdfs and kafka
and solar and spark and so on um and
then an application that does magic
whiz-bang stuff that i'm not going to
talk about
um but what i wanted to give you is a
very concrete idea about
what
the underlying you know quote-unquote
data platform is the short version is
that scaling data and i probably
shouldn't say this on camera yet because
we're in stealth mode but who cares um
you know scaling data is largely
building um a system that is very very
similar if not you know identical to the
use cases that splunk targets today but
on top of like big scale infrastructure
so so a lot of the use cases of machine
metrics and iq diagnostics and syslog
and like all this kind of stuff we're
very much building a system that pulls
in all that data does all the right
stuff and then presents it back to it
people to to manage these big
distributed systems
so for us
i'm going to sort of step through our
data infrastructure a little bit just to
give you an idea about where kafka fits
in and how we use it
so um
we deal very much with what i'll call
legacy data so syslog um files on disk
you know that can't be changed so we
work with like financial institutions
that go like look it's a trading system
it writes metrics to a file once every
second and no you can't change it and no
i'm not going to instrument my
application with your apis so you need
to find a way to get that data into your
system which is totally legit um
so we do a lot with this legacy data and
we
are subject to quite a bit of auditing
because we have to pull in this data but
we also need to live on the machines
where this data lives so uh for us we
needed to fit within um basically our
customer said you have about five megs
of ram um your agent needs to fit in and
you need to take no more than like you
know one percent cpu off of one core you
know that's what you get on a box so we
wound up having heard an agent native
code
and for us we cheated a little bit uh
joe talked about that the client apis
that are available we wound up using the
go api so we can compile down to machine
code
and be able to deploy statically linked
binaries the go apis are
mostly uh good i can tell you from
production use so if you're if you are a
go shop they're pretty they're pretty
fantastic at least on the producer side
which is where we use them
so our agent acts as a syslog server
that people forward data to
and we get data from syslog we are
starting to add a statsd port so
basically anything that speaks statsd
metrics for those of you who aren't
familiar with statsd it's worth looking
up um you can just fire statsd messages
at us
as well as things like that snarf
machine metrics like io time service
time and like all these kinds of things
they would scrape out of prof on a linux
box and scroll those away into the agent
you can do that and files and
directories what we actually do is to
gwen's point the schema thing was a huge
problem for us and we needed a way
to transmit data in a single format that
could be talked about and described
that was structured enough for us to
know what to do with and i'll tell you
how that works
files and directories come in and we do
some parsing on the agent and we create
what we call events and events are just
an avro object and they don't include
the schema because gwen's right
squirreling the schema inside of the
payload is a terrible idea
so what we actually do is we pre-share
the avro schema with both our producers
our agent java api and a rest api and
our
consumers and that schema actually
doesn't change and i'll show you how we
get around some of the schema evolution
problems
um we have love for j appenders and all
this other stuff but this stuff all
generates event data which is um i think
i can show you this yeah so this is what
our event schema looks like we have a
timestamp that's always epoch so
internally we always talk about epoch we
have an event type id which is
effectively the class of the event you
can think about it as a giant switch
statement at the receiving end so this
is how we get around the structured
versus like unstructured problem so
basically if you give us a time stamp a
type that tells us how to interpret the
body which is a bitering and a bunch of
key value pairs this type acts as a
class downstream so this is how we dodge
the whole problem of what is the schema
of data moving across kafka it's always
the same and all of our consumers that
are then responsible for getting data
into downstream systems know and
understand the schema in reality if we
needed to evolve it we can
it's just an average schema we can add
fields and there's some evolution rules
you have to obey but we can do this
today
this also opens up the door for we can
have built-in event types in our system
that are completely opaque so if
somebody's building a new system and
you're like a data platform team
we say that if you receive an event type
you know type id one
then
just take that event and store it on
disk don't bother looking at the body
don't bother looking at the attributes
we just take that data in and deal with
it later
so this allows people to send completely
arbitrary data
our source field looks like an amazon
arn if you if anybody's used amazon so
it's basically for us it's
low physical location colon host name or
ip address colon service group like web
servers or load balancer group a or
something like that and then the service
you know which is like nginx or httpd or
something like that so we have this sort
of strong set of four dimensions that we
use for things like filtering and
grouping and all this other good stuff
and the attributes are just key value
pairs
so whatever you want to give us you can
give us
and that's the format of the
the events topic and we actually
what we tried to do is create what is
equivalent to like a twitter fire hose
for your data center so this one event
topic contains
heterogeneous events as they move
through the system and if you are
interested in a particular type of event
you're you can build a custom subscriber
and latch onto that topic and then just
filter for all event types that you're
interested in and that gives you a full
tap so for security applications that
are interested in you know login events
from a web application or ssh failed
events that have a specific event type
you can steal those off of this this one
queue you don't have to worry about
schemas and you don't have to worry
about which topic that data is on and if
people add new applications it sort of
magically shows up in this topic
that
for us this is one of the things that's
very interesting about having lots and
lots of partitions on a single topic our
data rates today
are somewhere between 1 to 10 terabytes
an hour depending on the customer so
that's that's what we do today
um through
some number of kafka brokers that winds
up being different for different people
right so the question is if you're
interested in just one type of events
one type of event do you have to read
everything and in this case uh the
answer is yes by default
we support the ability to take events
filter them and shove them back onto
another topic so like if you want to
excuse me you can do that
and we do do that in a couple cases um
so we basically take an event off and
then if it matches a certain pattern we
shove it onto a separate topic that's
lower bandwidth
the the downside to that is you're
you're trading latency for processing
time you know like you you know the
drill
um so for us we ship oh and i should
have mentioned it before the the parts
that are colored in blue here are the
parts of our system the other parts are
um
open source projects that we don't
really touch or muck with
so this event schema and we expose this
we actually don't try and hide our
schemas from customers and things like
that so when they want to
like build some you know custom
subscribers we let them do that
um we do include what we call our hdfs
consumer and our solar consumer
um and those consumers are
sort of like what gwen described with
the the flume case where you have like a
sink that deals with like the conversion
from that event type
over here to a storage or processing
system specific type on the other side
i'm going to talk about the guts of that
in a second because that's where like a
lot of the durability sort of fanciness
happens but
those systems in turn right to their
constituent you know processing and
storage systems and we actually have
started
adding streaming support
um today
the
uh we're currently using spark streaming
but i'm this close to ripping it out of
the system in favor of anything else
because of
well and and i want to be really clear
here i think that spark is a fantastic
system spark streaming is a whole
different animal and it's just not there
yet in terms of production quality and
again i'm coming at this not from having
an engineering team of 10 phds i have to
build software and ship it to fortune
500s where it just works
and once you start getting into like
auto commits that aren't bound to when
you write to disk and like all sorts of
craziness and it stops just working i
can't ship it um i also can't ship scala
code when the byte code changes with
every freaking release um
don't even get me started um
you didn't start me i started either
it's all the same to me um
so at the at the far right hand side
here there's the the magic scaling data
application which i'm you know not going
to get into during this talk because you
know i'm not a sales guy but um
but uh the the application itself is
like multi-engine aware so we basically
take data in and we use spark and we use
impala and or hive uh depending on the
version of hadoop and like what features
are available
query hdfs for like trending reports and
all sorts of other magic stuff and then
we use solar for like your typical
faceted full text search like show me
all events where the word error appeared
by the way that's not a useful query in
any in any data center
it's all you know you want like a
classic case of like a hard to decipher
like series of log events
take the and our test case we take the
kafka broker logs and zookeeper logs and
shove them into our own system and if
you can't figure out what's going on
we're not solving a real problem so
so this is sort of what our system looks
like what i'm saying is it's complicated
stuff right so so this is our system and
sort of how we use things and i'm
talking really fast mostly because i'm
born and raised in new york and also
because i want to answer questions
but um
so we've done this and i got to tell you
having this sort of shared uh having
this well-defined schema allows us to
make our consumers and producers dead
simple and any new application
automatically knows how to deal with
data already knows how to deal with
stuff this is the inside of our
consumers and we have to jump through
some hoops because you know we needed
the ability to
uh manage offsets
you know in a very fine-grained manner
because we're primarily dealing with
hdfs semantics where files aren't
durable until you close them and yada
yada yada and eric what about append and
no not really because we're writing
columnar formats and all sorts of other
good stuff
so this is the inside of our hdfs
consumer we also have the ability to as
data arrives transform that data and
sometimes it's simply
mask this field for compliance purposes
like take a credit card number and drop
it
only take event type 100
or
do some field level mapping or something
rewriting or change the time zone or you
know whatever the case may be
um
so as we we basically have multiple
threads each thread
is
has an instance of the actual kafka
consumer class which gives us a
dedicated connection to kafka and this
has to do with like the way commits or
the the commit is we didn't want to use
like the super low level api so instead
we cheated and used the high level api
but used one connection per thread
because we don't really care and i know
that
jay and team are working on making the
apis better so um so we punt it for now
this kicks out our event class which is
a generated aggro type we shove it
through this sort of library of
transformation functions which are
basically take a produce b and we sort
of you know churn through a bunch of
transforms we always spit out
avro objects in memory
and
from this point up is the same in all of
our consumers
and even customers want to build custom
consumers can use this code it's all
just library code it's this last piece
that makes it specific to hdfs or solar
or whatever the guess would be so this
avro object that comes out in the case
of hdfs we use the kite apis uh if
you're not familiar with kite it's a
project that i started at cloudera that
i'm very excited about so kai takes this
data and writes it to hdfs and deals
with partitioning and metadata
management and all sorts of other cool
features
and you can
configure kite to spit out either
parquet or avro so this is where we vary
the the type of underlying storage
and if you configure it in such a way it
updates partition information and hives
so that if this automatically creates a
new partition hive becomes aware of that
partition so like magic just kind of
happens throughout the system
we also needed the ability to deal with
things like kerberos so we deal with
that for strong authentication
and we needed the ability to write data
sets as different users
so pretty common is that you would have
multiple subscribers
that are pulling a copy of the data and
writing a cleansed version for you know
without personally identifiable
information in one data set for
you know
marketing but in the security data set
all of the original information is still
present but it's restricted to a
particular group so we needed to be able
to sort of deal with low-level hdfs
permission controls and all this other
stuff um so so that's that's why we're
able to read from multiple topics but
also write to multiple data sets
um and i can go into you know whatever
amount of depth um
how am i on time
i'm good
so um i'm probably out of time joe tells
me i'm not so i'm very excited um so
we'll fit in some questions and this is
a subliminal message um so
um
does any of this make sense does anybody
have questions about any of this stuff
yeah
um
since you're
a wrapper
that's a great question so the question
is is there you know is the overhead of
using a serialization library like avro
sort of uh
significant if
we're doing byte array copies and and
things like that as part of the
serialization um there there is some
amount i mean whenever you're
serializing from type a to type b you're
inherently doing some kind of copy right
because it's effectively different bytes
um
so
so yes but you always have to have some
kind of encoding
and
for me even though i i jump up and down
and i scream and i yell and i tell my
developers the schema will never change
inevitably i will be so wrong and it
will need to change and again like this
is like for people building internal
systems enterprise software ends up
being pretty different
you know rolling upgrades and backward
compatibility and like all those kinds
of things are not secondary like they're
first class features and if you don't
have them like the other guy wins so for
us
i can defeat that overhead by telling
the customer they need four machines
rather than three you know and that for
you know basically what i'm telling the
customers it's twenty thousand dollars
capex to buy one extra machine or forty
thousand dollars like you know two extra
machines and like a three thousand
dollar a year opex to run that machine
or whatever it winds up being
that
price tag is significantly better than
the system will be down for the next
eight hours while i upgrade you
um and they're more than happy to take
that load
for us again like we're doing
one ten terabytes an hour of data
with three copper brokers and an end to
end latency which is the metric we
really measure from the time it's
produced to the time it's queryable and
it returns in the solar query
around 400 to 500 milliseconds so we're
not going to be doing high frequency
trading but we're certainly not to
beautiful produce jobs um and that's a
pretty good margin you know for most of
our operations folks
yeah is your solar is it solar cloud or
is it elastic
it's absolutely 100 solar cloud and i
have a whole diatribe about why it's
solar versus elasticsearch
elasticsearch is fantastic technology
but
reinventing your own consensus protocol
and being really susceptible to split
brain and then throwing away a bunch of
documents is a really really weird side
effect right so it's hard distributed
systems are hard like that's that should
be the closing slide in everything
you know the first rule of distributed
systems is don't
right don't write distributed systems
yeah
right uh
some topics
i think we're perfectly fine to have the
notion of subtopics the problem is would
you push that i mean sorry the question
was uh if you if you're trying to filter
out a particular event type um
you know rather than read through all of
the data as it's streaming into the
consumer ideally you'd only ever receive
the event types that you're interested
in you would sort of declare that
someplace and the notion of sub topics
that are like views on top of other
topics or like a better description
would potentially give you this the
problem with that is you're pushing
knowledge of the payload into the broker
and then you get into the cases and
allen's nodding so i know i'm right um
so so the problem with that is that
you're pushing user code into the inside
of the system and then when inevitably
you need to update those rules now
you're doing hot deployments and like
you have all these like weird side
effects of like
do you deploy the same code across all
three replicas of the same topic you
know you get into weird synchronization
cases and it's way too complex than just
saying buy an extra box and it just
works right so like i think at the end
of the day the answer is keeping it
really really simple
from somebody who has to debug a
distributed system like by proxy you
know like on the phone like what does
log say you know like it's really really
hard to figure out
you know um
i've tried grip you know like it's just
terrible
yeah yeah so um are you updating the
solar indexes
in real time from kafka and did you
modify the mapreduce indexer and if you
did
so a couple of things and i'll answer
them in variable order just keep
guessing one is
scaling data's building application
having spent four years at cloudera
building nothing but infrastructure i
don't want to maintain infrastructure
for the sake of infrastructure so
anything we touch that touches the
actual infrastructure we have to
contribute because i don't want to be
unhooked for maintaining it that's what
you guys are for um
it's not true i mean
um the the other problem is uh so in the
case of what do we do to feed data into
solar our consumer does micro batching
where it basically pulls out a bunch of
events and shoves them into a sewer
document list it's there's no map reduce
in there it's just directly impressive
it's doing the risk
excuse me it's just doing a rest call to
shove data into solar
yeah on the topic of uh schema
versioning
so this is kind of a good idea
i have no idea
is using a topic for schema version
maybe an agent to translate a migration
strategy like we've been batting this
around yeah i hope it's really a good
idea so the question is
if you don't
so the question is if if if you have
multiple versions of a schema do you do
something you know like use one version
of schema per topic and try and manage
it that way i think in reality if you're
asking yourself questions of versioning
step one stop inventing serialization
protocols and use avro protobuf thrift
whatever
and have like seen evolution rules
i would not do that because the
topics in in kafka aren't free
like you're ordering guarantees or
perpetration like you know there's all
sorts of side effects that come from
that
and for each topic for each partition
there are log files and you're basically
taking what might be sequential io
writing to one topic potentially like
one or smaller number of partitions that
might line up with disks and turning it
into effectively random ios like the
more files you add
that rests on the same physical devices
you know you're actually permuting the
the i o operations right multiple topics
well right so if you have multiple
topics
served from one broker
they turn into multiple log files like
under the hood which means that there
are multiple file descriptors which
means the disk head you know is no
longer real now i'm fudging a little bit
because like you always have multiple
partitions per disk you're just turning
that into a much bigger number which
potentially changes the semantics of of
reads
design yeah it does until the consumer
falls far enough behind
that it can't read from hitchhike so
like kafka is really good in the case
where your consumers and producers are
roughly moving at the same speed but if
you get a case where consumers disappear
and the classic cases you know something
terrible happens to hdfs or something
terrible happens to solar and you've got
like three hours of downtime and all of
a sudden it comes back and all those
consumers go like give me everything
from three hours ago and like you know
your phd starts flopping terrible things
i think am i out of time
no i'm good
bring it
it's really intimidating to talk about
kafka in front of
the guy who wrote it
but also
and i don't know how many people know it
but i was one of the original developers
on flume
so this is really weird